bonjour à tous je vous remercie d'être
présent ce matin et d'être aussi
nombreux dans cette salle avec ma
collègue rapporteur Sabrina sebahi nous
sommes ravis de vous accueillir à
l'Assemblée
nationale votre présence illustre tout à
fait les attentes dont nos travaux ont
fait l'objet cette attente en tout cas
prouve que la Commission a été une
réussite et qu'elle a ciblé les bons
enjeux et soulevé les bonnes questions
apprèci mois de travail voici le moment
de vous présenter les conclusions du
rapport de la commission d'enquête
relative au dysfonctionnement au sein
des fédérations sportive ce sont des
conclusions
attendues premier appel que je souhaite
faire le sujet a été délimité par ma
collègue Sabrina sbahi puisque c'est
dans le cadre du droit de tirage du
parti écologiste nupes que cette cette
commission d'enquête a vu le jour
sabrina est la rédactrice du rapport et
en on est donc la porteuse deuxième
rappel la commission d'enquête est un
élément phare du droit de contrôle des
députés elle dispose de prérogatives
spécifiques comme l'audition sous
serment ou encore l'investigation sur
pièces et sur place elle n'est
évidemment pas un pouvoir
judiciaire troisième rappel la
Commission est transpartisane par sa
composition réglementaire d'abord il y a
eu du respect entre les membres un bon
travail collectif entre la présidente
que je suis et Madame la rapporteur que
je
salue notons l'exception du
rassemblement national qui n'a plus
souhaité siéger à partir du 28
septembre pour commencer je souhaite
revenir sur l'histoire de notre
commission d'enquête d'une part une
création en conférence des présidents le
20 juin dernier 2023 donc les travaux
ont commencé avec les auditions les les
premières auditions le 20 juillet
2023 le rapport que nous vous présentons
aujourd'hui a été adopté le 19 décembre
2023 par les membres de la commission il
est donc le fruit d'un travail
conséquent les travaux ont pris la forme
de nombreuses auditions au nombre de 92
auditions sous serment avec 193
personnes auditionnées 133 heures
d'écoute et d'échang donc un travail
colossal quatre contrôles sur pièces et
sur place ont été effectués par collègue
rapporteur des centaines de
contributions écrites et de témoignages
ont été
reçues dans la chronologie des auditions
d'une part les victimes que nous avons
pu auditionner puis les associations les
entraîneurs les sportifs les directeurs
les présidents de fédération et les
ministres
ensuite je souhaite vous dire qu'elle a
été l'esprit de notre travail nous avons
voulu accompagner la société qui bouge
continuer à libérer la parole
j'ai par ailleurs une vive pensée pour
Catherine Moyon debec Sarah Abitbol et
Angélique cochier entre autres je suis
convaincu que notre commission a fait
bouger certaines lignes et encourager la
prise de
parole notre objectif premier était de
dresser un constat rapidement les
violences sexistes et sexuels sont
devenu de cœur de notre travail et avec
gravité certaines auditions étaient par
ement marquante des propos poignants et
forts avec quelques témoignages
particulièrement douloureux tout cela
nous a bien sûr marqué et au plus
profond j'ai vraiment souhaité que nous
portions un regard extérieur ce regard
il est normal sur les fédérations
exécutant une mission de service public
ce regard nous a permis d'identifier un
certain nombre de
défaillances j'estime pour qu'il y ait
une bonne vitalité démocratique au sein
des fédérations et du mouvement sportifs
il est ensable qu'il y ait davantage
d'organes de contrôle enfin un rapport
c'est évidemment des préconisations ce
rapport compte 60 propositions je vous
invite donc à en prendre
connaissance je veux d'abord dire que je
salue les travaux et les avancés
réalisés depuis 2020 à l'initiative des
ministres Roxan maracinaanou puis Amélie
oua casterin fin 2019-2020 est un
tournant et je pense par exemple à la
création de la cellule sign à sport il
serait faute de dire que rien n'a été
fait un travail conséquent a été initié
des propositions doivent permettre de
poursuivre et de développer cette
politique
publique si je ne peux pas valider 100 %
des pages du rapport je partage les 60
propositions qui sont issues du travail
transpartisan beaucoup émanent des
sportifs et du monde sportif sans
défleurer la présentation de ma collègue
je veux vous dire que je souhaite
pleinement la création du d'autorité
administrative indépendante extérieur au
mouvement sportif chargé de l'éthique et
de l'intégrité du sport disposant de
solides prérogatives je partage la
nécessité absolu de rendre les violences
sexuelles sur mineurs imprescriptibles
et de reconnaître l'amnésie traumatique
dans le cadre de la prescription pénale
le renforcement l'élargissement de
signal sport me paraît essentiel et plus
que souhaitable pour conclure et avant
de céder la parole à Madame la
rapporteur je remercie mes collègues et
Madame la rapporteur pour leur travail
et leur implication
nous avons tous souhaité agir en faveur
du sport des sportifs et de l'intérêt
général le sport n'a pas de couleur
politique je suis persuadé que cette
commission aura participé à changer au
mieux notre société pour que le sport
reste un plaisir et une chance pour que
les pratiquants se sentent protégés et
en sécurité les lieux de sport devraient
toujours rester des espace de confiance
et
d'épanouissement nous aimons le sport
les sportifs et le monde sportif le le
sport permet la transmission de belles
valeurs et renforce la cohésion
nationale et le lien social le travail
de cette commission reste aussi un
hommage à tous les bénévoles de France
au 3,5 millions d'acteurs essentiels du
mouvement sportif ce rapport restera une
contribution essentielle à la Grande
Cause Nationale pour 2024 souhaité par
le Président de la République l'activité
physique et sportive pour toutes et tous
je vous
remercie
alors merci madame la
Présidente bonjour à à toutes et à tous
Tout d'abord permettez-moi d'exprimer
mes remerciement comme l'a fait ma
collègue envers la présidente de la
commission d'enquête pour notre
excellente collaboration et
particulièrement pour son objectivité sa
neutralité et sa rigueur tout au long de
nos travaux son engagement inébranlable
pour la transparence et la recherche
chche de solution constructive a été
essentielle pour la mission que nous
avons eu ces 6 derniers mois je voudrais
également remercier toutes ces victimes
notamment Carine Moyon de becc ça a été
dit Isabelle de Manau Sarah Bibel ou
encore d'autres Angé angélique Cochi
toutes celles et ceux qui ont pris la
parole qui ont eu le courage de prendre
la parole et qui ont commencé ce travail
pour lever l'omerta dans le mouvement
sportif c'est le courage de ces femmes
et de ces nombreuses victimes qui a
permis de révéler les dysfonctionnements
structurels dans le mouvement sportif le
rôle des médiia je le dis est également
primordial puisqu'on s'en est rendu
compte aussi tout au long des travaux
très souvent malheureusement il a fallu
que cela soit médiatisé pour que les
affaires soient traitées je suis honorée
de vous accueillir aujourd'hui en tant
que rapporteur de cette commission
d'enquête après 92 audition cela a été
dit 193 personnes auditionnées et plus
de 130 heur d'audition alors nos travaux
se sont beaucoup reposé sur de nombreux
rapports qui nous ont été transmis dans
le cadre de nos travaux je pense au
rapport de l'inspection général de
l'éducation des sports et de la
recherche au rapport de la Cour des
comptes euh les les rapports de l'Agence
Française
anticorruption les les participations en
tout cas de la Haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique et de la
Défenseur des droits qui nous ont
transmis aussi des notes qui nous ont
permis de nourrir nos travaux le rendu
de ce rapport marque une étape
importante de notre travail qui vise
depuis le commencement à identifier à
analyser et à comprendre les
défaillances qui ont pu survenir au sein
des fédérations et du mou sportif ces
dernières années les fédérations sont
des institutions cruciales pour le
développement du sport en France tant
tel qu' structure l'organisation du
sport dans notre pays ça a été dit il
n'y a pas un territoire à travers notre
pays où il n'y a pas un club de sport un
terrain de foot un équipement sportif
c'est un vecteur de cohésion sociale
c'est important de le rappeler ces
fédérations sont aussi un groupe social
percuté comme d'autres par les
évolutions de la société les attentes de
nouveaux publics les rapports à
l'autorité le regard porté sur l'al et
la différence mais parce que le sport
occupe une place de choix dans la
société française non seulement en tant
que source de diverstisement et de
compétition mais aussi en tant que
vecteur d'éducation de santé et de
cohésion sociale les fédérations doivent
être sinon exemplaires agiles dans leurs
capacités à témoigner qu'elles observent
les changements qu'elles font des
propositions pour s'y adapter et
qu'elles font acte de vigilance et de
détermination les fédérations Français
jouent en effet un rôle essentiel dans
la promotion et la régulation des
activités sportives et elles ont la
respons abilité de la formation et de
l'encadrement de la sécurité et la
sécurité de tous les pratiquants or ces
dernières années des dysfonctionnements
ont été relevé par les médias qui
concern le fonctionnement interne de
plusieurs fédérations sportives et au
cours de notre enquête nous avons
constaté des approximations parfois des
omissions même des mensonges et un
manque certain de préparation de la part
de plusieurs acteurs du mouvement
sportif nous avons été étonné à
plusieurs reprises par une certaine
légèreté apporté aux réponses de
questions qui nous paraissent
fondamentales
particulièrement dans le cas des
violences sexuelles et de discrimination
ces constatations sont non seulement
inquiétantes en elles-mêmes mais elles
ont également une signification
symbolique importante sur l'état
d'esprit sur le fonctionnement
intellectuel sur les valeurs finalement
qui guident le nombreux dirigeants du
mouvement sportif alors oui certaines
fédérations ont déjà pris des mesures
qui vont dans le sens d'une partie de
nos propositions je pense par exemple au
handisport ou encore à la natation mais
les comportements que nous avons observé
durant ces mois d'audition éclairent
symboliquement et souvent concrèt
les conclusions de notre enquête il
mettent en évidence des lacunes parfois
graves dans la manière dont certaines
fédérations gèrent et traitent ces
problèmes sensibles nous ne reviendrons
pas sur les signalements qui ont pu être
réalisés concernant les parjures qui
font aujourd'hui l'objet d'enquête du
parquet notre mission ici est de tirer
les enseignements de ces comportements
tenus devant l'Assemblée pour proposer
des solutions constructives et des
recommandation visant à renforcer la
protection des athlètes la protection de
tous les licenciés et à améliorer le le
fonctionnement des fédérations sportives
pour le rendre plus transparent et
conforme aux normes qui prévalent
partout ailleurs nos missions ici notre
mission ici est aussi de relier les
défaillances observées dans les
fédérations à l'absence assourdissante
de l'État dans ses fonctions de contrôle
d'encadrement et de sanction du
mouvement sportif notamment fédéral nous
avons ici ainsi constaté un effacement
total du rôle de l'État qui est très
inquiétant il délègue ses compétences à
des organismes tiers qui ne permettent
pas de faire exercer son rôle de tutelle
au ministère avant de vous présenter les
recommandations fortes de notre
commission permettez-moi de souligner un
point crucial nous sommes convaincu que
le mouvement sportif ne peut plus être
seul juge des mot qui le gangraine un
grand nombre de mesures à prendre
doivent être portées par une autorité
administrative indépendante à l'image de
ce qui a été mis en place dans le
domaine du dopage il faut mettre fin à
l'impunité au Mertin et l'un des mots
qui a été le plus prononcés pendant les
auditions de cette commission d'enquête
il est impératif que les les fédérations
sportives françaises se dotent d'une
gouvernance plus transparente et d'un
système plus rigoureux pour garantir la
sécurité l'intégrité et l'éthique dans
le sport cela nécessite un changement
fondamental dans la manière dont les
instances dirigeantes du sport
fonctionnent notre rapport formule des
recommandations dans ce sens mais nous
devons également nous assurer que ces
recommandations seront mises en œuvre
rapidement de manière efficace et
indépendante notre mission ici est de
faire en sorte que le sport français
retrouve sa place en tant que modèle de
valeur d'éthique et de fairplay nous
sommes déterminés à travailler avec
toutes les parties prenantes pour
atteindre cet objectif et nous espérons
que nos propositions contribueront à
bâtir un avenir meilleur pour le sport
en France ça a été dit l'une des
recommandations qui traverse finalement
tout notre rapport et la création d'une
autorité administrative indépendante
chargée de l'éthique personne ne peut
être juge et parti signal sport serait
rattaché à cette autorité permettant aux
victimes d'être plus en confiance pour
libérer leurs paroles cela a été dit
d'abord signal sport souffre d'une
méconnaissance aujourd'hui du public
donc il faut le rendre beaucoup plus
visible beaucoup voilà il faut que les
victimes puisse savoir que ce dispositif
existe pour aller porter plainte en tout
cas faire des signalements quand c'est
nécessaire il est impossible au vu de
nos audition de laisser perdurer des
cellules de signalement dans les
fédérations elles-mêmes donc on propose
que tous les dispositifs qui existent
aujourd'hui en interne des fédérations
soient supprimés pour que une seule
porte d'entrée existe ça soit celle de
cette autorité administrative
indépendante on l'a vu cela contribue
d'ailleurs à l'entreoin qui n'incite pas
les victimes à signaler des
comportements et des violences sexist et
sexuelles mais aussi d'effets de racisme
de discrimination ça a été dit le le
périmètre de signal sport n'est pas
clair et en fait en réalité cela ne
permet pas de traiter correctement tout
ce qu'on a pu voir tout au long de nos
auditions cette nouvelle autorité sera
dotée d'un pouvoir de sanction
financière à l'encontre des fédérations
sportives ne respectant pas leurs
obligations et engagements en matière
d'éthique elle pourrait aussi prononcer
des mesures telles que l'inégibilité ou
encore la suspension conservatoire pour
des dirigeants mis en cause là aussi on
l'a vu parfois beaucoup de laxisme
beaucoup d'inertie beaucoup trop de
temps avant que des sanctions soient
prises lorsqu'il y a des faits qui sont
commis et surtout lorsqu'ils sont suus
parce que très souvent ça a été dit
aussi pendant nos auditions beaucoup de
monde savait et pourtant il ne s'est
rien passé confier ses enfants à des
adultes doit se faire dans la confiance
ce contrat de confiance passe notamment
par le contrôle d'honorabilité que
doivent passer les bénévoles aujourd'hui
le seul fichier contrôlé est le fichier
figes qui recense les auteurs
d'infraction sexuelles violentes nous
avons ainsi découvert au cours de notre
travail que le contrôle d'honorabilité
ne prévoyait pas de contrôler le casier
judiciaire alors que c'est vrai que tout
le monde pensait que c'était le cas en
réalité on contrôle le figs et si il y a
un signalement on contrôle le casier
judiciaire nous on propose de
généraliser le contrôle du casier
judiciaire cela permettra d'être
beaucoup plus efficace et donc la
réalité ce qu'on a pu constater dans le
cadre de nos travaux c'est qu'on a
laissé parfois des adultes accusés
d'agression sexuelle ou même qui ont été
condamnés encadrer des enfants et
continuer donc à travailler ou à être
bénévolle auprès de clubs sportifs le
contrôle d'honorabilité permet
normalement de veiller au contrôle des
adultes qui ont des enfants en charge il
n'est que partiellement mise en place
aujourd'hui de manière imparfaite et pas
pour l'ensemble des intervenants avec
mineurs nous proposons donc d'élargir ce
contrôle à l'ensemble des personnes
interagissant avec des mineurs avec
contrôle systématique du casier
judiciaire et surtout nous proposons de
retirer une licence accordée à un adulte
reconnu coupable d'abus sexuel
particulièrement grave nous proposons
d'élargir le billet nominatif à la
majorité des grandes manifestations
sportives l'actualité nous l'a encore
rappelé le weekend dernier avec l'arrêt
du match asse 1 an unidais les cris
racistes sexistes et homophobes n'ont
leur place ni ici ni dans la rue ni dans
les stades il n'y a pas de règle
d'exception ce n'est pas parce qu'on est
dans l'incinte d'un stade que c'est
permissif le racisme les discriminations
l'homophobie sont des délits ils n'ont
pas leur place dans le mouvement sportif
donc le billet nominatif contribuera
ainsi à mieux cibler les coupables pour
les sanctionner par la suite ce qui fait
que nous n'aurons plus la possibilité
d'avoir quelqu'un qui serait interdit de
stade à Lyon qui pourrait aller dans un
stade à Marseille par exemple pour tenir
des probos homophobes pour assist comme
on a pu le constater les fédérations
sportives représentent 17 millions de
licenciés et autant de cotisations pour
faire vivre les clubs et les fédérations
plusieurs scandales ont entachché la
rémunération des dirigeants de
fédération alors même que des milliers
de clubs vivent uniquement sur du
bénévola parce qu'elles ont dé légations
de service public les fédérations
doivent avoir une obligation de
transparence vis-à-vis de leur situation
financière et ce pour éviter notamment
les niveaux de rémunération anormaux
comme cela a pu être décrit dans le
cadre de nos travaux nous invitons
toutes les parties prenantes y compris
les fédérations sportives les athlètes
les clubs et la société civile à
collaboré avec nous dans cet effort
crucial visant à garantir un environ
sportif sûr inclusif et respectueux pour
tous nous croyons fermement que le sport
doit être une force positive pour la
société et nous travaillons dans cette
optique pour bâtir un avenir meilleur
pour le sport français je vous remercie
pour votre présence aujourd'hui et je
crois qu'on est quelquesuns de la
commission d'enquête à être présent
aussi pour répondre aux questions merci